j'ai déjà fait plein d'aspects km n'est
pas celui là à mon pote celui là il est
spécial c'est sur invitation g1 paul
d'un brusque au genre nouveau riche le
fric lui sort par les oreilles
bon on vient de l'autre bout du monde
qu'est ce que tu as prévu porno torah
jamais rien vu de pareil
quelqu'un devrait être là c'est quoi
tout ça qu'est ce qui s'est passé ici et
si je faisais partie du truc c'est ton
pote était en train de lui parler je ne
reconnais pas si bien qu on est en
russie avec un mec qu'en fait tu connais
de rien t'es dingue ou quoi c'est qu'un
je vais sûrement pas rigoler il se fout
de nous là il faut pas nous
je n'ai pas attendre tout le monde doit
se détendre et l'étende faut qu'on sorte
et qu'on se mettre en sécurité
qu'est ce qui te torturer
je sais que tu as deux facettes mais je
ne connais pas le vrai toit dans no more
day
tu sais combien ils payent pour regarder
des gens comme se faire découper en
morceaux diffusés ça
[Applaudissements]
c'était une nuit bizarre je me reconnais
plus